what up you might have noticed we
skipped past mac and charlie die parts
one and two that wasn't an accident uh i
know how to count dude
we are saving those episodes to recap at
our upcoming live shows in philly next
month and we'll be posting those
recordings for everyone to enjoy in
october
but for now please enjoy who pooped the
bed
yeah it's kind of like a flavored coffee
that's
had some
something added to it i've been watching
some 80s movies and looking back at a
time when people wore sunglasses inside
all the time
yeah and it was a cool
it's a cool idea
i don't know how you walk around your
hair's greased
[Laughter]
is it possible that you greased your
clothing maybe mary elizabeth you out
for sure
once you get some momentum too like it's
like it's hard to start with them once
you
go yeah yeah by the way these are like
luge chairs
the opposite works too like if it were
not if it were not greased and
everything if it's like particularly dry
and your clothes are particularly dry
that also creates a slippery surface you
know what i'm saying a double dry too
dry things because it's like if it's
slightly moist it's gonna stick it's
gonna stick yeah but if it's dry to dry
as a bone if both things are dry yeah if
i squirt down this chair or my my pants
a little bit well you know what if i
squirt my chair or my pants squirt
yeah if i'd like take a little like a
spritzer you know like uh something to
answer i squirt my pants
well that's another way to do it but
no like something that you would
aggravate a cat with
by the way i this is my sister would
kill me for so i don't know if we can
put this on the podcast but uh are we
rolling on this yeah yeah all right
we'll put it in just just in case my
sister used the spraying the cats thing
technique to you know whenever the cats
would like jump on something she didn't
want to jump on she'd do the thing she'd
spray him with the water bottle and it
and it really it worked so well
she did what she did with her kids yeah
i think they told me that before yeah it
worked of course it works
when they were getting up on the couch
yeah i think well if they if they did
something like touch something they
weren't supposed to touch or you know
got into something they weren't supposed
to get into just give them a little like
[Laughter]
that's general i don't know yeah i mean
did she have it on the single stream or
the wise yeah
like a suggestion of like you're
irritating me but you can't ask her i'll
ask her um yeah should i text her right
now
text message from glenn his sister
courtney hey c on our podcast are you
okay with me telling the story of how
you'd spray the cats when they did
something wrong and that it worked so
well you tried it on the kids too
response from courtney sure it was
really just elliot that i used the spray
bottle on because he liked to scream i
only did it a couple of times and then
all i had to do was just place the
bottle where he could see it which would
cause him to rethink his decision
laughing face emoji did i tell you that
when we took elliot for his first
haircut the stylist tried to spray his
hair with water and i had to yell don't
spray his head or he will think he's in
trouble spray the comb spray the comb
laughing face emoji
response from glenn that's amazing
what the kids turned out all right you
know what they they actually they turned
out great her kids are cats are all
[ __ ] up are awesome yeah the cats are
are messed up
[Music]
welcome to the podcast everybody here we
are back in studio yeah
we got slippery chairs and i took my
sunglasses off already
rob's in his linens well it's well
that's also part of the look it's very
hot
outside here in los angeles
it's kind of in the studio though we
keep it cool in the studio i just turned
off the air though for glenn sitting
under the vents so oh i'm going to tell
you so
it could get toasty we might have it's
only going to get up to 72 and then it's
going to flip right back on again oh
okay yeah okay what is it what does it
mean
70 70. okay yeah 72 is a little a little
warm
chilly
for me yeah i like i like to keep your
house set at
73.74 do you want the sunglasses because
that that sometimes that'll make it i
think it could change what like
depending on the house like a 74 and one
house and a 74 in another might be a
very different feel true
let me see those on you oh you look
great
these are very similar to my own
sunglasses actually yeah they look nice
you know it is really nice to wear
sunglasses like when you're on camera i
have to say because it it it makes you
feel less i get why people do that you
know why like you mean like on a red
carpet or like in a movie no no no i
know i mean when you're not when you're
playing a character although that's cool
too but no when you're just when you're
yourself because then it's like wearing
it's like a mask a little bit for sure
you don't feel like people can see into
into your soul you know you know what i
mean they can't read your fear they
can't read your fear and your
vulnerability yeah yeah yeah sure yeah
and they can't see the uh the cocaine
and alcohol that's right they can't see
they can't see how much cocaine and
alcohol is in your system that's why
like i said in the 60s 70s and 80s that
that look got perfected indoors and then
it just kind of went away now was that
because okay so you're saying it's
because we're talking dilated pupils in
red red yeah i think it was the kind of
thing you're like hey look i'm going to
a laker game i've been up i got up
around so now we're talking about jack
next we're basically talking about
jacksonville yeah yeah we always were i
just want to say no go back and watch
some of those old
games like from the mid 80s like
showtime yeah there's a lot of people
that took cues from jack
sure male 1 yeah and people just came in
there you know probably
half cocked from the night before sure
and uh and it they look great the hats
you guys wear are sort of masks like you
used to wear the baseball hats you
haven't been wearing them well because
our hair's
you're short it requires uh
no maintenance right this one kind of
just kind of this is
you know i never have a short hair style
and this has been great yeah yeah yeah
it's nice i don't have to think about it
i know it just is you come in mine's
just starting to come back enough that
i'm like okay pretty soon i'm gonna have
to
make that decision about whether i put a
little effort into straightening it out
or put a hat on
straightening it out
[Music]
no i don't believe i've ever
no dropped the deuce in my bed
is that a thing that's well you have it
you were just
a wee lad
oh well okay yeah yeah yeah good point
good point you don't remember it but it
did i ship my crib you're saying you
shoot your crib yeah
maybe maybe i have a system that really
shuts down if it's not a good place to
poop like you know like when i travel
you know if it's a if they're like an
airplane day usually that's tough
everything locks everything tightens up
and then it stays on lockdown for a few
days and like i'm all out i'm out of
whack you know yeah yeah it's no good
yeah traveling is is a real mess on the
digestive tract it's i mean on the uh
yeah the poop tracks yeah it does it all
shuts down and then and then it it comes
eventually comes out it was infuriated
yeah and if you're furious with me
you're not shutting down the works what
if you while you were traveling ate
dairy
oh to counter
yeah get it going that could work that
some cheese on some cheese
could work [ __ ] on a plane is you
know i don't know when it hits you on
the plane no it's no good now i'll do it
because i'm not holding it i'm
i'm the odds i will not hold back i yeah
and if and if i feel myself holding it
back i'll force it out
i'll get an i'll i'll sit on that toilet
and i'll you just hear screams from the
airplane
to the front of the airplane
ouch you vile mass
yeah yeah i'll force that [ __ ] out i'll
tell you what you can use some
visualization techniques to to coax a
poop out have you guys ever tried that
that works
not only have i not done that i've never
heard of anything like that you're
visualizing a a nice elimination
is it okay to talk about on the podcast
where people [ __ ] themselves in their
cars listen no no it's not that it's not
that powerful it's a useful tool do you
want to talk a listener through that
maybe maybe they're sick
it's weird we've had listeners um call
in while pooping while pooping yeah and
maybe someone's in the car right now and
they want to
sure well
you know part part of what makes
podcasts great is you get
sound medical advice
you know uh sound like advice
writing experts so
now this this is probably something that
it just won't be for everybody because
it's a little strange
but believe it or not
in the past this has worked for me
if i'm a little constipated
this is i can't believe
i don't know why but picturing a dog
pooping
will make me poop
you know how they get in that weird
okay that is all over the back cake that
is also cute
and they just like you know
[Laughter]
there's so much happening right now i
don't know why i swear and i swear it is
true
it is true i i was about i was gonna
make something up because that's so
weird but i was like nah [ __ ] it i'll
just i'll tell it because it
it works now why am i not picturing
human pooping
first question now i have done that i
have done that but my mind always goes
to a dog pooping
and so i just go with it and and it
works there must be some like freedom or
ease with which the dog does it that
makes you feel like i think that's what
it is i can free you up you're like
because because the human animal is is
all up here and yeah you know what i
mean and the dog just just does you got
the dog's free you just you got to get
into the mind you've got to get in your
animal mind to do this animal act i
think that's right i think okay okay
yeah okay so i know there's a lot to say
there's a lot to unpack yeah yeah
okay i think number one for me is buddy
i've known you for 20 years and i've
heard everything like the story you were
telling about your sister and the cats
i've heard that 10 times sure and love
it every time but i've heard it many
times in fact everything we talk about
on the podcast i've heard many times i
have to present it to the first time
yeah i've ever heard that well that's
not something you'd usually you know but
now i want to know what else i don't
know i feel like you know everything
about me
they've forgotten
i'll continue to do that but i can tell
you that there's i've never heard that
before
no i don't think i've ever told how long
has this been going
[Laughter]
when on you first fantasize the dog
pooping while trying to
yeah
i don't know i i honestly don't know and
it's not something that happens very
often uh it's only when you really need
yeah it's a it's a tool that is like you
know at the bottom of the bag how often
how many times a year would you say you
picture the dog
you run say fantasize
there's a certain amount of fantasy oh
yeah it's a fantasy of sorts yeah sure
um if i had to guess how many times in a
year uh you know five okay maybe it's a
rare how effective is it
very
eighty ninety we're talking a hundred
percent hundred percent of the time it
works okay uh what type of dog yeah i
mean i was that's that's
like a 30 pound dog like a 30 pound dog
a medium-sized dog yeah or yeah it's not
a small dog because that i can't relate
to that
uh
but it's not like
yeah i need to be you know what i mean i
need to see myself in the dog i guess
and in some ways but you're not like uh
you're not like a golden retriever or a
lab you're something these are two dots
dogs are too dumb oh okay something
smaller
it's like a yeah is it always the same
dog and i i can't it's not it's not a i
don't visualize things that specifically
uh i this is why i think it's why i'm
i'm so bad at like drawing is it king
charles spaniel what kind of yeah yeah
it's a mud it's a it's a
is it your dog
uh well you know i mean i only recently
became a dog owner i know but since
owning a dog do you now picture your dog
long hair short hair
it's not long it's gotta be short hair
so you can see it's not a shaggy dog do
you see the dog's poop or do you just
see the picture coming out of the dog's
butt wow
yeah i picture the dog actually
squeezing the turd out now this is a
this is a this is a
late in you know
whatever i'm not gonna
we're already dealing
with this yeah
we're dug in wait when you walk your dog
now and you see your dog poop does it
like trigger you no
so it's only when you
imagine
it not when you actually see it in real
life that's that's good yeah no it
doesn't it doesn't know i for one i'm
gonna try it next time i'm a little
blocked up listen don't overthink it it
really works i you know or hey listen if
whatever you want to picture you know
you know
you can picture whatever species you
need to picture whatever species
that helps you definitely go for it
that's right i i like the animal thing
because i think it
it like yeah it's like
i don't know that do animals get
constipated
yeah if something's gone wrong with the
diet
yeah they could i guess they could right
how how often are you so you're saying
you're only constipated about five times
a year then right
yeah but you're only the only you only
utilize this
yeah yeah i'd say that's right i'd say
that's right because i i probably would
utilize that tool
75 of the time if i'm having a
constipation episode
this is great so yeah yeah yeah yeah are
you guys going to share back and now
tell glenn what you fantasize about
while you're i don't think i'll tell you
some sauerkraut in my system
yeah yeah some probiotics all those
healthy probiotics and sauerkraut
that that helps the whole thing that'll
get things moving yeah yeah yeah maybe
not immediately but eventually you know
what's weird
vegetables makes me poop
interesting i always have to poop after
i eat sushi what type of sushi is a very
broad category you mean like immediately
afterwards
any raw fish
yeah
all food makes some category
well i don't i mean is it maybe it would
be is it is it snapper that's making you
poop or you only like albuquerque well i
don't know because i don't i don't sit
there with just a plate of one fish is
it the rice you know what i mean i'm
getting a variety of fish as one does
with sushi yeah true you know it's it's
so i don't know which one it is it could
now it could be a certain fish it could
be a certain fish if i can target oily
ass fish that's making things move now
if i could figure that out i'd be able
to let go of the dog technique because
i'd just be able to be like oh you know
what sea bream
but then you'd have to carry around raw
fish yeah yeah yeah
are you gonna well what if you picture
the fish oh pooping picture
and pebbles well what if you picture a
seagull taking a crap all over
somebody's car because it's wet it's
always eating
too wet it's just not you know it's wet
and it's white you know a dog puts out
like a nice log and that's like if you
if you want a dog
or like that's too much well it's too
much and and it's so casual it just
almost seems to fall out there's no
effort
i get it so horses don't take a [ __ ]
they just [ __ ] as they're going like
that it's just yeah which seems
unsatisfying right like it's like you're
not
getting the you know ceremony yeah
you're not getting the little endorphin
rush that you get from a guy
endorphin rush
that one felt good oh god yeah that's
that is the thing man you know
especially afterwards when you're just
like man
i really i let it all go today
you know and you give yourself a little
pat on the shoulder and you're like i'm
gonna have a good day well i guess we
don't have to talk about personal
stories we could talk about the episode
i suppose
uh i laughed throughout wow uh one of my
favorites i loved it really what are
your favorites one of my favorites that
we've done in the in the review which is
amazing because because part of why we
made that episode as i recall was in
reaction to how averse you are to like
any kind of poop or fart joke yeah you
know and and and i always give in
because you guys are right it's funny i
mean that's what the whole i think i
realize
everybody already thinks of us as the
dick and ball yes poopy show and that's
why why do we want to do a whole episode
about it and you guys were like well
because it's funny because it's funny
and [ __ ] that but i'm like oh yeah we're
going to lean into it we're going to
lean yeah we'll lean harder into it yeah
we'll lean so far into it that it's like
absurd we'll we'll start by saying
poop isn't funny we'll have a character
you know who's like wants to do
something sophisticated and cool by the
way the opening of the episode right off
the bat hey you guys what are you doing
tonight what the hell kind of question
is that yeah you're asking us to predict
the future dee how can i predict the
future
well there's a new martini bar opening
up downtown i thought maybe we could do
something different tonight jesus where
is this [ __ ] coming i should just watch
that stupid sex in the city movie oh my
god when will that show die never
apparently dee you tried this [ __ ] 30
years ago when that show first came on
the air we're so angry with her yeah
what are you talking about
why would we want to do that that's
crazy like i you're asking me to predict
the future i don't know what i'm going
to want to do tonight yeah
and we're playing checkers and drinking
beer we're playing yeah yeah yeah on a
tuesday or something i don't know what
we established it being yeah no i
laughed throughout this entire episode
too i love this one
i loved it it is funny it is funny and
and i i would say that like your
aversion to putting poop jokes and fart
jokes in the show is less to do with
whether or not you think it's funny and
more to do with not wanting to be
stigmatized yeah yeah which we were and
are and whatever and still what it is
yeah that's fine yeah and that's
something i i should have accepted at
that point just leaned all the way into
it which we did which we did well i
think you i think but i don't think you
like i don't want to be the poopy dick
and fart joke show either
um you know what i mean
but
i'm okay with it
it's better to accept at this point and
uh yeah maybe at some point you were
like yeah why do i want to be paraded
around and celebrated
you know whatever but like now i'm like
whatever if it's just [ __ ] goddamn
funny then great that's even frank
cranston's great oh my god
you got turd yeah you got a turd i'll
take a look at it
okay
well
it's definitely poop
uh yeah we know that guy yeah
whoever it was seems to have been eating
newspaper
all right well now we're getting
somewhere which one you idiots was
eating a goddamn name it's gonna go both
ways dude really yeah what else this
appears to be a piece of a credit card
inconclusive
yeah how do you guys know him was that
just casting or we knew fran no we knew
him yeah we knew fran um
around
yeah yeah just i mean yeah i've been
i've known fran for for a couple years i
mean we weren't like close friends but
he was one of those guys i think like
our age and in this sort of group of
people you'd see at auditions yeah you
know yeah i can't remember if any of us
had worked with him before i had never
worked with i'd never worked with fran
i'd i'd only like i worked with anytime
socially
harrison ford yeah yeah but i got cut
out of that so i worked with oh harrison
ford right uh-huh technically but no one
would know hey you worked with the the
entire cast of campfire stories yeah
that's true
that's true wonder boys michael douglas
i'm wondering we were the wonder boys
yeah you were sitting next to
next to katie holmes
yeah that's
right
let's get back to bring it back charlie
let's talk about it a lot of classes i
love this you get a little bit of a
conversation going about poop here yeah
love love the stuff love the stuff with
the ladies cannot wait to have artemis
on okay
artemis is so good in this episode it's
the first time we really kind of like
cut her loose right and started to
figure out well we'll talk more about
her character when we have around but um
yeah they're dynamic the three of them
together
we've talked about caitlyn stunt which
is in this episode which is the best
stunt anyone has ever performed on
television because
it was the most likely to break
somebody's neck
try that huh
excuse me
it's not even just that it's not just
the
running into the car that's the
that's the coup de gras but it's the
wobbling yeah the wobbling all the way
the whole thing is
like the whole thing's just
extraordinary and trying to find i mean
she uh she i think we said d has a size
13 shoe uh-huh and so we had to get she
doesn't so we had to get a size like one
shoe to make it look like her foot was
so big so she was wearing it she doesn't
have a small foot i mean she's got she
doesn't have a giant foot she has a tiny
little foot yeah i mean it's not tiny
but it's a it's i don't know it's so
funny maybe i'm mixing i'm mixing up
with the character yeah i think she's
got like rather small females it's just
her feet were [ __ ] huge
just because we always make jokes
yeah that's why she assumed and that's
why also the audience assumes that as
well
yeah we assume that her feet are
enormous did we get that right in the
roller skating episode did she say she
wears a size 13.
we actually i think we had somebody look
that we were like i know that we've
referenced her specific size of shoe we
need to make sure that you know we're
getting that right in this episode i
love the shop woman's like oh my when
she cares
she's just as a very tiny girl oh
ladies can i help you hello we are here
for the manolos and what's your shoe
size 13. oh
my
she'll be happy to tell us exactly i
love how friend says she's hey i bet
she's a size 8 you got turd
yeah terry
he he doesn't ask like
do you have a turd there he goes you got
you got turd you got turkey you got turd
you got turd the little glasses the
magnifying glasses yeah
a lot of kind of figuring out where we
were going with the frank and charlie
relationship just in that episode right
and the sleeping together she got back
so fast i just texted her you texted
caitlyn what shoe do you wear size eight
oh wow but she thinks i'm probably
buying her men or women's
she probably thinks you're buying her
shoes
she's smarter than that she knows what
we're talking about
yeah yeah and she wants to clarify that
she does not have a size 13 footage
that's right in reality that's right
that's fair
that's fair that's well that's not you
know are there things about you that
people assume about you uh
from the show that it bothers you that
they assumed that tons
oh really yeah i mean it doesn't bother
me it's i find it fascinating
and maybe maybe i do this too but i find
it fascinating how
often people assume we're exactly like
our our characters i think we all do
that i think that's a natural
thing sure i get that you know i get
that if you if you if you meet one of
the a cast member of a show that's been
on for 10 years
so like it's very rare for someone to be
completely unlike their character right
like
yes like like
if a guy plays like a psychopath in like
all movies
sometimes those people also tend to be a
little bit crazy in real life
see i i i actually find the opposite of
what
yes
crazy you know they can pull it off tell
me about this before you take a little
bit of the personality and you and you
blow and you see the extreme version of
it but
but mostly i mean we've been running a
very successful television show for 15
years 17 years very soon and people just
i'm amazed at how often i'll be in the
middle of a conversation and someone say
you're not as dumb as i thought or
something along those lines like oh
you're smarter than i thought you would
be
[ __ ] what do you think we're doing we
show up and just say a bunch of words
and then it just
appears on television yeah
so i guess it does bother me so you fly
into a rage like in a moment's notice
i know it doesn't bother me
and now please enjoy this collection of
moments where the guys were exactly like
their characters
no no no no you know you're wrong no
because you don't you're wrong that's
crazy that's crazy you're [ __ ] that's
great
and i rolled down the window and i said
[ __ ]
you are not getting in front of me so i
don't know what you're gonna do but you
better do it right now hey everybody
grow up why are cars not like just giant
round rubber balls
you know like
like why didn't we do that so like it's
like ah [ __ ] sorry i ran into you good
thing we just bounced off each other
you know did these pants tear naturally
or is this this is a natural knee tear
yeah because they the rest of the gene
looks
i've been if you look closely at the
podcast i have worn them most every
episode
and uh as they tend to do um
i've always wanted to know what it was
like to actually sink in quicksand
[Laughter]
now if somebody were to give you a
paralytic you know as a paralytic a
paralyzing drug of some kind and pop you
on some quicksand and just slowly let
you sink that's pretty [ __ ]
diabolical i think that would work
you [ __ ] [ __ ] that was not an honest
mistake it was a dishonest mistake
[ __ ]
[ __ ] wow now hold on
[Music]
we are supported by athletic greens we
are hey did you guys uh take your greens
this morning sure did oh yeah you got in
your greens for me
it's every day and i i mean literally
every day i cannot start my day without
some ag-1 green powder by athletic
greens i'm at a point where i can
generally feel whenever a given vitamin
or nutrient is
five to ten percent depleted inside me
and so you know i know when i need to
re-up ag-1 has 75 high-quality vitamins
minerals whole foods sourced superfoods
probiotics and adaptogens
well they make it with constant
iterations based on the latest science
and third-party testing so i buy
that it's helping you stay at
equilibrium to make it easy athletic
greens is going to give you a free
one-year supply of immune supporting
vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your first purchase all you have to
do is visit
athleticgreens.com sunny again that is
athleticgreens.com
sunny to take ownership over your health
and pick up the ultimate daily
nutritional insurance
and now a word from our sponsor better
help
glenn a little while back on this show
you were talking about how hard it is to
care for plants how finicky they are is
this where you're going to compare
watering plants to taking care of your
brain uh and your mental health charlie
that's exactly what i would do is that
what it was it could take a combination
of strategies and new methods you know
for for instance seeking out support
online like you do with betterhelp
betterhelp is online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
so you don't have to see anyone on
camera or even speak your mind out loud
if you don't want to uh it's also much
more affordable than traditional therapy
which can really add up for me because i
bring a lot of baggage you know what you
got to do you got to water those plants
robbie you know taking care of your
mental health is paramount no matter who
you are and since better help can match
you with the right therapist for you
in under 48 hours uh it's a great way to
get started today our listeners get 10
percent off their first month at
betterhelp
betterhelp.com
sunny so check it out and tell them we
sent you that's betterhelphep.com
sunny
i i would have thought that just having
met you guys after watching on tv for so
long i would have the only thing i would
have assumed is that i would assume you
were more outgoing charlie just because
the character is like so loud and kind
of boisterous that i figured but you're
a little more shy and reserved than i
was expecting well it depends on the
situation
but i like uh i like a stage
you know like
i do feel
most comfortable like performing like
when we were doing the
i've like when we were reenacting the
scene on the podcast i was like okay
that's my happy place oh yeah me too no
i'm much more comfortable as a character
than i am as myself like yeah you know i
mean i i
i i am not comfortable you know i i
admire
actually your ability to
get up on stage and just kind of give a
speech you know like any time we do a
premiere you usually
you know i think you're always the one
that gets up and
you know gives a like little speech to
the audience or whatever and you make
jokes and you seem totally relaxed and
comfortable and i just i'm not
comfortable standing up in front of an
audience as myself at all i'm extremely
uncomfortable with that i wouldn't say
i'm as uncomfortable with it as the
average person just because i think
isn't that
like widely understood to be like the
biggest phobia is standing up public
speaking yeah so i wouldn't say i'm as
bad as that but um
definitely much more comfortable as a
character than as myself oh yeah
always struggled with that on the red
carpet like whenever i was doing
interviews and stuff i'm like my am i me
and my chara what am i like what am i
doing here do i have to perform do i
have to be funny sometimes i don't want
to be [ __ ] funny i just want to
be me
i don't know if you guys do this but
like i have to almost get into
character to do an interview but it's
not a character it's the character of
glenn
it's like the glenn character
on a little bit yeah you got to turn it
on yeah i think the same should be said
for public speaking i mean i think yeah
yeah i am very comfortable doing it but
it's only because of practice
i'm just as i'm just as nervous each
time but i just remind myself that i've
done it and i and i prac what's the key
for you do is it is it just trusting
that trust trusting that it's worked in
the past and so
you kind of know the the the feelings
you can trust yourself up there and then
and then what's interesting too is that
you start to crave a little bit of the
fear and anxiety a little bit more and
i've heard that before for sure yeah
because that's kind of the juice and
it's awesome no that is the juice no i
was always in the same place which is
like what's the worst that can happen
like truly what's what's what what could
what is the worst thing that could
possibly happen right now you stumble on
your words in a way that's goofy and you
just sound like a [ __ ] idiot you use
the wrong word use a word wrong yeah
you just navigate through it and move on
and you find that most people don't give
a [ __ ] they want to be there kind of
they want you to be quick
they want you to say some funny things
maybe say it's you know well it depends
on the crowd right because i mean if you
like i i you know when you're getting up
just to speak in front of everybody at
you know a premiere of the of it's
always sunny you know everybody's
actually excited to hear what you have
to say that's actually scarier to me
scarier to me because the expectation
that's what it is it's like the
expectation is like well i look at those
stand-up comedians i can't believe it
what a what an
terrible job
i mean yeah it's so unbelievably
difficult to get up into a room so the
people who were there they paid a lot of
money to be there and they love you but
they will turn on you and you talk to
some of those stand-ups they're like the
audience is there for me and they will
turn on me in 30 seconds yeah if you
don't sometimes they bring a book
sometimes they bring it sometimes they
will bring a book
when i gave that a commencement speech
you know i i was pretty nervous about it
i mean at first they my college asked me
and i said yeah sure
i'd love to do that and then i was like
what did i just agree to you know like
people are gonna have their families and
then there's going to be an expectation
that i make them laugh right so
it was like how do i approach this and
you know i was watching other speeches
and getting kind of like in my head
about like how
how am i going to do this i don't know
how to do this
and you know what i did was um
i opened up a final draft document i
wrote like in two
yeah uh interior uh auditorium charlie
takes the podium
then you know my character's name and
then i just started writing it as if you
know as if it was like an episode of the
show or something it was like in this
this what i would say and then and then
i felt comfortable in that space because
it was like all right well i know how to
uh
write for a character
yeah
and then
and then and just kept working it like a
scene of a movie or
a
tv show yeah and that got around that
kind of went around and got pretty viral
right uh i mean as i recall i mean i
think it was pretty well received oh i
felt good about it i thought it was
phenomenal i mean it's been a while
since i've seen it but i remember
watching that being like damn i was
proud of it i was proud of it i was like
oh i i got my jokes in and then i made
some points and then i got out of there
you know like but
but i don't know to do it again i'm like
i don't know did you did you were you
reading cards or even though you were
successful
yeah but you but but how about this
whether you want to or not you know you
could
and that's true yeah he also knows the
amount of work it took to to to come up
with something that made him comfortable
also it doesn't
look making a movie or a tv series or
whatever is scary but
i aspire to do that so i want to do it i
don't aspire to be a guy who goes and
gives speeches so i'm like i did i did
the thing it went well and like
kind of feel like you got like you i got
down the black diamond without breaking
my legs i don't have to go back up
you know like i did it i did the thing
yeah yeah it's on youtube i'm gonna cut
it into the podcast right here
well you are graduating from an
excellent school today
alumni have gone on to be ceos
politicians professional athletes
however this year
you will get to receive wisdom
life lessons
knowledge
from a man who's made a living
pretending to eat cat food
now i do however have some
qualifications some insight
because like you
are becoming today i'm a merrimack
college graduate
thank you
i know what it took to get here today i
was in this fairy room
i sat in those uncomfortable chairs
i dressed like some sort of medieval
pastry chef
and i too desperately hoped
that my hangover would wear off
yeah
that one knows
if you can just make it in front you'll
be all right
but take note a quick observation today
apparently the higher you climb in life
the more ridiculous your hats will
become
like the one i'm wearing today or the
pope or pharrell
so if some way you fear success just
think of the hats
that should motivate you
it's great it's fantastic it's really
good
you guys would also give a great speech
you know if
you went to college
you know you were respected by your
institution who doesn't really respect
oh i think that's very true human beings
well they don't you know it's like
you know you got i got classically
trained and i was meant to
you know go on and do great things as an
actor and uh yeah you know boy and
instead he made an episode about poopies
poopies and turd mergers yeah what a
shame i do want to talk about this real
quick but i i'm curious
when you did that speech i don't
remember did you have uh did you have
like little cue cards did they have like
a prompter i how did you remember it all
right i didn't remember it i think i had
the the you had it in front of you yeah
i think i had the script yeah yeah yeah
on the podium and you had i'm sure you
had it like semi-memorized yeah i had it
so you weren't like staring at the thing
no right it's like you know i find cue
cards very difficult to read like uh
like you know in a situation where you
have to look at them i kind of go blank
and can't see it yeah yeah yeah so i
sort of have to memorize what i have to
do i mean if you if you're a cast member
on snl you're doing it week after week
you get used to just like okay yeah just
like anything i just read it right
i think that's a common misconception
that i hear all from a lot of people
which is that
you have like people like oh you must
not be nervous or you have a natural
talent to get up in front of people like
i don't think that's true at all for me
it's truly just practice so you talk
about the snl
people i i'm sure that there's a measure
of fear and anxiety that goes into every
performance but but it's definitely gets
easier and easier each week at least in
so far as you realize well i didn't
completely burn the showdown last week
and i figured out how to navigate the
cue cards or whatever the system is but
also i mean you
you're an actor so
like you know
you aspire to be an actor he's about to
be a tv host you're going to be in this
week
you're on the right track so what is
this you're you're what are you doing
i'm hosting kimmel you're hosting kimmel
okay yeah
by the time this airs though that will
happen yes so it will have either gone
over
really well or really terribly or just
kind of like meh but either way i'm sure
we could cut it into
the thank you
thank you
welcome to jimmy kimmel live i am your
guest host rob mcelhenny
now you may know me from my show
mythicquest on apple tv plus
or as one of the five drunk
from it's always sunny in philadelphia
well i'm very grateful for everything
sunny has given me that's not what
tonight is about so let's forget about
sunny guys you're about to get to know
the real me
[Music]
i love that you're doing it though right
because that's life coming at you with
an opportunity that
you not something you aspire to do and
just being open to it and being like
okay i'll do it yeah right like uh yeah
i got a call from jimmy yeah what
happened how'd that happen he goes on
vacation during the summer and he's like
i need somebody to host the show and so
he brings on a series of guest hosts and
i've never done anything like that
before and he called and asked and it
sounded like i i said no
because it i was super busy and it
didn't feel like something i maybe i was
a little bit nervous
yeah i wanted to be you want to
and then everybody in my life said you
have to go do it so i said yes
it's an opportunity you
might not get again in life i probably
would have said no too right like that's
just not what i want to do but then
you're like i don't know what i don't
know if it's what i want to do because
i've never done it before i've never
stood up and given given a monologue
oh you go so you have you're doing the
whole thing the whole thing you get up
you do a monologue yeah i mean and are
you working we have writers on that oh
yeah yeah so it's so my day starts
tomorrow at 8 30 and i go in we don't
record until five or something like that
so so i spent all day rehearsing
which is great because i'll need that
and i don't know how it's gonna go i
really don't now were you gonna pop a
little xanax beforehand are you gonna
hit some cbd
nothing no
man
no i don't click on the nerves huh
shot a whiskey a little shot of
something well that might make that
might be fun but i think
and to i kind of enjoy the anxiety so i
feel like yeah that's a good game that's
a good go mode you know it's game time i
think the ant anxiety might like
bring it down too
i i enjoy xanax to help fall asleep from
time to time but yeah but to perform you
don't want to be sleepy out there you
don't want to [ __ ] the bed
yeah we probably should talk about the
episode huh as well
was the big speech the final thing
was it satisfying for you yes like okay
all the twists and turns it totally was
it was so well crafted well performed
and i remember being in the editing room
and thinking this didn't work we were
concerned that it wasn't going to work
not because if any artemis was amazing
it was because we hadn't found the score
quite yeah the score
and there are a couple things that we
judged in the episode that we didn't
quite shoot like um
when caitlyn's looking at all the poop
art yeah in the edit we kind of created
more like uh
sort of effects and things that because
just the footage that we had wasn't
enough just like playing out the same
the scene as it took place
i feel like my mouth is so full of spit
i'm such a hack man hold on
wow
the self-talk there man that's bad
self-talk i felt really embarrassed that
my mouth got full of
spittle then you called yourself a hack
i call myself a hack that's this thing i
know as if that has anything to do with
the amount of spit in one's mouth okay
sometimes i'm real hard on myself yeah i
know
yeah
we'll work on life
anybody noticed this
uh and anybody can go back and take a
look at it maybe we'll cut it into the
podcast
what is danny doing during that speech
do you know
he's falling asleep
he is is he almost there there are a
number of scenes throughout the series
and they get and and i think we should
point them out as we go where danny is
just asleep do you think danny was
he didn't like the idea that it was him
that was pooping the whole time
that that that does happen sometimes
right where he's like it's like go with
it but he's not yeah he'll go with it
but he's not loving the fact that it
could be it could be just that the
cameras were pointed over our shoulders
at artemis because it's such a long
speech and we were there for three hours
and that was just like what it was
he's an insomniac so he didn't sleep
probably very well the night before
that's true the problem is he's up on
that stool and if he tipped over on that
like
he could have cracked his [ __ ] head
open but
but he didn't he was just kind of like
nod and then like wake up and you could
see his his eyes like everyone cut to
him and he'd wake up
we should point that out every time it
happens
do you remember there was one scene
where he actually yeah where liam's uh
mcpoyle screams at him and wakes him up
oh yeah yeah yeah i cannot wait and that
was
you know it's funny because you're
thinking oh the character is just not
enough but i think yeah it was as i
recall from shooting that it was like
kind of warm yeah and we were all
sitting on that couch it was kind of
cozy it was really cozy and i think it
was like too much for his you know
sleepy body not to that's the fact that
that's what goes on that's a performer
that's so comfortable that he's like
close to sleep yeah yeah he's like so
many
do we get a rain machine for that
exterior shot of that that's effects
that's an effect that's a vfx shot
yeah we just added that in post
uh when
when we were breaking this story i have
a very specific memory
of you charlie
uh at the board
coming up with a lot of those uh beats
for the artemis story at the end i
remember you you just got on a jag yeah
and just like tore through
a lot of that like in the in the break i
i remember that too like you remember
that i do yeah there was like
horns we had a photo of me or something
just because my handwriting's so bad and
it was like green you know it was green
ink and i think i had on that like
philly's captain yeah we should try to
find that sort of jeff cat yeah steve
hornsby has it but like
and and just like lines and lines lines
and lines of the stuff yeah you know
like every now and then
you guys know this you kind of like
touring it comes to you like in a
it's happened to me maybe two maybe
three times total in the show i think it
was this episode
the the one where we pulled the prank on
d
and charlie worked yeah yeah where it
was just like
charlie mcdennis you and i wrote in one
day yeah yeah but i felt like that was
me riding your wave of like you were
like you were hot you know i was just
like
just like okay yeah well and and just
just plus it would be you know just tear
it up yeah does jojo be like that's a
great idea and then what if this but
sometimes one person gets on a roll and
it's just like yeah all right let him go
and don't stop him right because you're
like i remember specifically with the
prank on d being like i don't know if
this is going to work but i definitely
learned my lesson don't just get out of
the way and and let who's ever got the
vision for it just go
yeah people get hot yeah well yeah you
get you get into that you get into
you're in that flow state
yeah you know i don't even think i was
in the room for that in fact i may have
for the poop story i think i was like
i'm out you guys do the poopy jokes i
and i think i might have been breaking
the other story
credited writer on this episode yeah i
might have been just been breaking the
beast or the um
sex in the city but we also you know we
don't credit the the person necessarily
who even broke the story it's just
whoever wrote the
the draft or whatever but uh how did you
did the idea come out of like being
criticized for being like wanting to
attack is poop funny or not or did it
come out of like want to do a murder
mystery idea and then that just being
the
i can't really remember
because it's like clearly at the end she
gives a speech a la like uh
sherlock holmes or poirot at the end of
the yeah miss marple like the classic
detective speech at the end which
yeah i mean i think we
knew that that would be a funny way to
approach an episode of who pooped in a
bed right of like just trying to turn it
into a mystery yeah these characters
being like
this is all we care about now you know
and then
yeah and it works so well
against d story yeah yeah i don't know
sometimes it just works
the uh the score
uh under artemis's big speech at the end
was a riff on the score from beetlejuice
you guys remember that
[Music]
four turds
five suspects
so many many nameless victims
[Music]
the first poop was obviously frank
old and weak he had an accident that's
why he was so intent on destroying it
there are many turds before this weren't
there frank this was just the first time
you got caught wasn't it and then you
went and did it again the next night
or did you
i watched beetlejuice so beetlej there's
a scene
out of my mouth i don't know what's
going on today
spit just everywhere
you're ashamed
wow he knows you don't want to become
that old man
[Laughter]
yeah [ __ ] um you don't feel that what
we're saying uh the score that score was
it's it's a it's a almost a direct riff
on uh
i don't remember the scene in
beetlejuice but it was a scene in
beetlejuice and you get
meg maybe you can pull that up
[Music]
beetlejuice
beetlejuice
[Music]
beetlejuice
it's your dad
were you guys fans of like mystery
novels of like the great uh the great
detective mystery
characters like uh
marbles
i've become more of a fan i wasn't
really but i've
i'm getting
more and more into it i think i read the
hounds of baskerville when i was a kid
yeah but i don't sure like homes
you know catch little sherlock holmes
yeah yeah i used to read mystery books
all the time when i was younger i kind
of wanted to be a forensic toxicologist
for a while when i was oh so you would
have been the fran crans like you know
digging through yeah digging through
poisoning what's that that was what i
wanted to do poisoning like poisoning
cases oh that's that's the woman's
choice for murder yeah traditionally oh
is that right is that the most most uh
commonly used tool for murder that that
women use is poisonous yeah certainly
like um
historically yes because it was our
greatest point of access to murder you
guys yeah yeah feed you yeah you want to
eat [ __ ] oh
make it dinner oh god yes
slowly killing you with your food i
remember just a little bit psychological
torture too is a big big one i remember
reading a story of a woman who poisoned
her husband by taking um something it
was something out of the fish tank like
filters and she was crushing a little
bit of it up every day and like putting
it in his food and it took it was like
heavy metal poisoning but it took a
couple months yeah the the passive
aggressive equivalent of killing well
because if you don't have the the tools
of aggression
so you need to be passively aggressive
i'm going to go out in a limb and say he
probably deserved it i'm just i'm
putting it out there
i think if they're going as far as to
murder the person boy yeah it's probably
a real because like i mean just leave
leave the guy you're gonna get if you if
if you feel like you can't leave then
the person has to what are the
percentages of psychopath of murderous
psychopaths that are that are women now
they they exist yeah like let's not
pretend they don't exist they exist but
i'm going to say they're slim
compared to men well most murders
are
most murderers are male yes so in
general and then a subset of that are
serial killers and i'm sure like a
tinier subset of that are female serial
killers although you know that
they've driven to murder because of
women
yeah well right always because
usually the source of it right sure um
but women i feel like the famous ones
they get away with it for a really long
time because usually they work in like
nursing homes or like at orphanages or
stuff like that where they have like
access to lots of like the angel of
daddy murderers yeah oh sweet old lady
sociopath
that's a scary
scary thought a scary character right
someone who's
so sweet and kind on the surface and
it's just slowly poisoning you
yeah and that exists but it's very rare
yeah
very rare
it's especially rare that um
cross-gender uh couples murder together
so those are really interesting stories
also like men and women that team up in
order to kill together for fun for fun
yeah
to get up i found you i found my
performance yeah and how do you discover
that
but before there was before there was
online you know how do you broach that
subject do you get an inkling right and
you're like you see an opening and
you're like you test the waters well you
know what happens you go out on a date
and she tries to kill you yeah you go
home and then you try to strengthen
yourself i was gonna do the same thing
to you yeah i have an idea i have to
hear me out let's team up and then every
night you're also sleeping with one eye
open and that's hot
you don't know like at one point tonight
tonight she's gonna get me or do i get
her tonight
[Music]
guys a new season of nfl football is
almost upon us yeah yeah and you know
what that means loud and clear buddy
it's time to try out for the eagles
again no uh robbie boy um i don't think
so i'm talking about gambling baby okay
the old spread total money line all
right got to get ready for the nfl week
one action with draftkings sportsbook an
official sports betting partner of the
nfl to celebrate the return of football
draftkings is giving new customers a
can't miss offer bet just five dollars
on any football game and get 200 in free
bets instantly well that's a great value
to get you started i can attest football
is always better with skin in the game
yeah that's right draftkings is the
closest you will get to football at this
stage in the game
rob i'm sorry download the draftkings
sportsbook app now and use promo code
always to get 200 in free bets instantly
when you place a five dollar bet on any
football game that's code always only at
draftkings sportsbook an official sports
betting partner of the nfl minimum age
and eligibility restrictions apply see
the show notes for details
today we are brought to you in part by
bluechew bluetooth is a unique online
service that delivers a chewable and
much more affordable version
of the active ingredients in cialis and
viagra the little blue pill it's a
chewable tablet there's no pill
swallowing involved remember in the
matrix where morpheus opens his hand and
offers neo a blue pill and a red pill he
wouldn't be offering you any red
anything okay look i just i rewatched
the movie and like in the spirit of of
the reference to your point though who
does want to take a red pill it seems
like if you take the blue one uh your
penis gets harder right and uh your
erection lasts longer right now that
that sounds more fun to me than waking
up in a pile of goo um although it could
lead to a pilot
so
okay but just so we're clear in this
scenario the morpheus you're talking
about is one of blue chews licensed
medical providers who has approved your
claim and cleared you for a specific
strength of prescription am i right
that's right because that's the response
that's what they do at bluechew.com
um and it's it's very useful and it's
also efficient these guys are not going
to be in dusters or shades the approval
process happens entirely online and
here's a special deal for our listeners
try blue chew free
when you use our promo code sunny at
checkout just pay five dollars shipping
yeah that's bluechew.com
promo code sunny to receive your first
month absolutely free and guys there is
no spoon
oh no spoon
it's a matrix reference
[Applause]
have you guys ever pooped your pants
yes
once
only one time as an adult yes
and a full-on full-on
not like a leaky fart but like no no
i've nev i've never done that and i hear
people talk about like sharding or or
like looking in their underwear and
there's skid marks i don't know why
that's just never been my bad it's never
happened to me that's not your bad
nothing kind of all or nothing i i've
heard of people [ __ ] their pants
before
or [ __ ] the bed and um i thought man
i
that's just never gonna happen to me i'm
a grown adult i i don't have problems
with
incontinence incontinence is that that's
right it's incontinence um and then one
day i just straight up [ __ ] my pants a
full release yeah full out of the blue
out of the blue
out of the blue
okay so how old were how old were you 30
years i tell you i was in my 30s because
my son was born he was sitting i was it
was my turn to watch the kid
he was asleep but he was in one of those
like chairs that just like vibrate you
know like those little rockers and i was
i was working i was typing at sitting at
like a desk chair
and i just remember sitting there like
working and all of a sudden feeling like
some kind of rumble and then
like maybe i'm thought i had the far i
don't know what it was but it just
exploded i mean i laughed so hard it
came up no i there's no there was no
reason for it or why what happened wait
so it came up and out my shorts from the
top and through the bottom
when i say a bathroom was
six feet away i could i could see the
toilet from where i was sitting that's
not the point the point is you thought
you had something that wasn't a [ __ ] yes
you were ready to let it out and it was
a [ __ ] it was a full i mean so you did
think it was a fart but it wasn't a
little special it was a giant yes but
when i say i was i don't even remember
thinking like oh well let me just
squeeze this out it was just
oh i shared myself and i remember like
almost like like yeah yeah isaac sure
and i was laughing so and what dog were
you thinking about at the time
i was laughing so hard and i was like he
i was like i gotta wake my son up but
he's not gonna get it he's too young he
doesn't get it yet but i was i i called
kaitlyn my phone was there and i called
caitlyn i called her from the landline
and i was like when are you coming home
because i have to have you i wanted her
to come in to see the scene of the crowd
because it was
it was absolutely insane and she was
gone for hours and i was like i think i
could sit here for 20 minutes
but i can't sit here for two hours
and then i got up and yeah in a perfect
world i wanted her to come home and have
her just walk in and then just pretend
like nothing was happening and have her
be like it smells really bad in here
check the baby's diapers
just to complete the set because you
peed on her and she stayed with you so
you're like well if yeah if she can get
through this
man what a great bit like if
if she could walk in and i'd be like oh
i gotta i guess i gotta change the kid
and then getting up and like changing
the kid and realizing
[Laughter]
it was a wooden desk chair but it was
like did you throw the clothes away or
did you try to shorten your linens were
definitely
definitely the underwear got thrown away
oh yeah but i don't know if everything
you wanted to salvage the pants like
it's my favorite pair of jeans you might
be also for anybody who does not have
anybody who's got kids and is hearing
this story and recognizes that at the
time i was changing diapers all day long
you get so used to it at that point in
your life you just don't give a [ __ ]
anymore and i'm the kind of person that
gets like i used to gag when i would
like pick up dog poop now
there's a like uh there's a moment
in child rearing where you know in the
beginning it's like the poops are like
they don't smell like anything yeah it's
just the breast milk or and
it's kind small
like sausage biscuits yeah yeah and then
and then they start eating solid foods
yeah that's nice and then it's like a
homeless man has broken into your house
and crapped in your kid's
diaper and snuck out you're like what is
this yeah and then you get used to it
and i haven't yet i've never had
explosive diarrhea in my pants i don't
know how i've had so many like
running to the toilet sweating
to be clear this was not diarrhea yeah
this was this is a full like solid but
then was squished by the weight of
gravity yeah yeah it wasn't one of those
things where it was not okay i'm gonna
ship my pants and i can't get to the
bathroom on time it happened so fast
that you're not sure what happened it
never happened before and i don't think
it'll happen again until i'm until i
actually i had a solid one come out one
day when i was a kid
my buddies
he had a basketball net in his room it
wasn't like a high ceiling so we would
just like
i don't know like uh we wouldn't even be
it was like a little mini thing yeah
yeah a little nerf bath put on the door
we were just like playing and i remember
having my sweatpants on and then i just
remember feeling something like fall
down my leg and get like trapped in the
ring of the sweatpant you know
and i was like i think a poop came out
and it's like in my
in my leg
and like going to the bathroom like
shaking like pulling pulling the
sweatpant out and then dropping the dirt
into the toilet i pooped down my leg
i was like 12. but like a real that's
that you and then and that you knew what
it was like to be a horse yeah you know
you're just doing your thing just
playing came out i jumped too hard or
whatever it is
you went up for a long time wasn't a big
one like a little hard round one but
out of came
meg when was the last time you shoot
yourself i just have never i i gotta say
that my um
i have like a thing i i haven't reached
that point uh of being comfortable
enough with like
poop talk yet so i'm i am now
fantasizing about lemons which is what i
do when i get nauseated
that's all right hey sometimes you got
to face your fears you got your face
part of life man but everybody everybody
does it that's true and everybody poop
my husband's family loves telling
stories about [ __ ] their pants and
like farting and stuff so yeah really
yeah and so
english i know i thought i was wearing
to this like proper british family and
then that's all they want to talk about
they're from around the countryside
right yeah
they live in london too but
um but they tell a really funny story
about my father-in-law um he's an art
dealer and he was at his first
he had set up his own
art dealership and he was going back to
christie's for the first time like to
impress all of his friends and during
the auction he [ __ ] his pants and then
ran to the bathroom and took off his
boxers because it was like contained in
there and he decided to hide them in the
cistern
of the toilet like and then he was like
oh it'll be fine like i'll i'll get out
of here and whatever it'll be somebody
else's problem goes home tells my
mother-in-law his wife about this funny
thing that happened to him and she's
like wait were these your boxers that
you've been wearing since school because
they had his name sewed into the to the
band of it so he had to go back to the
auction house he brought an empty
briefcase and he went back and like
reached
a briefcase
um boxers in there went out put some
rocks in it and like threw the briefcase
into the thames
i say [ __ ] it let's lean all the way
into it let's have a whole show where
listeners call in and tell us their poop
stories who pooped the show i don't
think i've ever shut my pants i've
definitely sharted sure that's you know
i have a specific moment i'm [ __ ]
your pants
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i
guess i mean i haven't had a full
release a little bit of poop is still
poop
yeah but they have a word for it so
there must be a reason to distinguish
take it easy man yeah nobody's yeah
nobody's telling you you're dumb
and you catch a little throw up in your
throat and then you swallow it back down
you're like oh i just burped a little
throw up it's not the same as like
vomiting for three hours in the toilet
that's throwing up yeah that's just if
you were to spit up a little bit of bile
from your stomach and it came out of
your lips and onto the the plate in
front of you that's vomiting that's
reflex yeah but if you had to
but if you were like on a date and you
had to either
vomit a tiny little bit or streams of it
out you would rather the former of
course so there is a difference like you
would rather shart on a date that's a
microphone then [ __ ] your pants
it's a micro [ __ ] in your pants that's
what it is it's a it's a uh sort of a i
don't know yeah a smaller version of it
that's that there's a continuum
yeah yeah there's a spectrum i usually
can find a raspberry pi and you know
like hold it long enough to find a
restaurant this happened to me recently
when i was in new york and coming home
and i had to like ask the guy like to
find a gas station i'm like i'm sorry
you got to pull over yeah
and then like two days later marilyn and
i went to a restaurant and we walked
with russell and we were walking home
and bumped into dax and uh
saying hi to him and the kids and
everyone and like
and i was like oh i have to run back to
the house uh
and
let mayor elizabeth keep walking and i
ran all the way ran ran stopping every
few seconds to be like are we talking
were your hands blades were you running
that fast
terminator
yeah yeah yeah
style run or are we talking like a like
a swift jog
while clenching your butt cheeks
um swift jog yeah clenching the butt
cheeks stuff so you weren't going all
out like gathering yourself okay like
baron tells an amazing story that
involves him and jennifer lawrence and
like i think we should have people call
in and tell their story i think that's a
good idea and we have a whole episode
you know if you don't want to watch it
don't watch it [ __ ] us and if you want
to listen to it we should have celebrity
poop stories that's what i'm saying
but then but then let's mix it in with
you know
listeners and creeps yeah so we'll reach
out to a couple of our friends
and have them uh what call in and tell
their poops stories yeah maybe zoom do
that maybe we could do maybe we could
zoom in
okay i like this i like this plan well i
think we've learned a very valuable
lesson today poop
poop is funny he's funny poop it's funny
poop is funny